the jurogan experience oh my god i read
tick tock's terms of service i went down
a tick tock rabbit hole yesterday yeah
it's good i stayed home smoked a little
weed and i started reading up on tick
tock yeah oh my god i'm gonna read you
this because this is so crazy is it good
or bad bad it's so what are you saying
it's a bad place to be listen to this
this is uh from tick tocks privacy
policy all right it said we collect
certain information about the device you
use to access the platform
such as your ip address um
user region
this is this is really crazy uh user
agent mobile carrier time zone settings
identifier for advertising purpose model
of your device the device system network
type device ids your screen resolution
and operating system app and file names
and types so all your apps and all your
file names all the things you have filed
away on your phone they have access to
that file names and types key stroke
patterns or rhythms so they're
monitoring your keystrokes which means
they know every [ __ ] thing you type
wow battery state audio settings and
connected audio devices where you log in
from multiple devices you will be able
to use your profile information to
identify your activity across devices we
may also associate you with information
collected from devices other than those
you know you use to log into the
platform meaning they can use other
computers that you're not even using to
log into tick tock they can suck the
data off that that's what you're
agreeing to
when you download and start using tick
tock
that's wild it's insane my question
would be do you think they did that they
created tick tock just on purpose to
have all that 100
wow i think they saw that people are
addicted to social media and they came
up with the most addictive version of
social media which is tick tock it's the
most addictive by far it's the best for
sucking people in my my kids are [ __ ]
hook line sinkered on that [ __ ] and i
know a lot of other people hook line and
secrets to grown people it's good it's
good and it starts playing things
immediately the moment you turn it on
it's like playing you a new thing
playing you're like
you just sucked into it and all the
while it's monitoring your keystrokes
your audio settings but by audio
settings that means it has access to
your microphone that means it's
listening to you right now just tell me
how it ends man it ends with china
having all of your data
and if they develop if they get all the
data currency then what well you're
[ __ ]
because if they look what's going on in
china i don't know if you've seen this
but they they pulled tanks in front of
banks to stop people from [ __ ]
rioting because they just took all their
money did you see all that
yeah did you see that [ __ ]
oh my god they have shut down people's
accounts and they're doing a social
credit score system in china and they
have digital currency
videos of tanks shows chinese military
exercise not bank barricade yeah
according to china and the ap but if you
see what what's going on over there with
the digital currency what they have is
the ability to tell you you can't buy
gas
like hey theo we don't like the way
you're living your life so you're not
going to be able to buy a plane ticket
china's a dump man
i mean there's cool people and i like
some of the food but
i think that i think it just i don't
know i don't like the way they're doing
it all
what any military exercise they're doing
when they're putting tanks in front of a
bank is intimidation at the very least
do you think the people there even know
what freedom is anymore you think
they're just so brainwashed they've
never had freedom like we have so no i
mean they weren't even capitalists for a
long time right it was a communist
country and then they realized you know
what in order to compete we got to
loosen this up a little bit and let some
people get greedy and make a shitload of
money and that's what they did they kind
of have a hybrid of capitalism and
communism you know because in the old
days it was like the government would
tell you what you do okay the government
would tell you what you get paid all
right and you just did what you had to
do you did what you were told right but
what they do now is they allow people to
get extraordinarily wealthy so some
people they develop industries they
develop businesses and they work in
conjunction with the government like
every business that exists in china say
it's a tech business
you are an arm of the government you you
know you're not independent from the
government like that was the the the
concern with huawei
like when they were trying to when they
banned huawei phones from being
distributed in america do you know about
all that i don't think so it's not the
gas station they no that's that's uh
wawa right what is that
you're talking about flip phones it's
it's it's a h
no they have super complex okay um
smartphones like huawei it starts with
an h
huawei had some amazing phones oh huawei
huawei okay
okay um and they had amazing phones that
they were using like they they had like
100 megapixel digital cameras before
anybody did
really like high-end phones but they
also had network devices that were
stealing data fancy yeah well they were
stealing they were using them as spy
devices okay you know like all this [ __ ]
that i was reading about tick tock well
that's they have
a similar situation with like their
routers so that's spying so they're
spying basically 100 but what do they do
once they have all this information like
what's the end goal to having it all
over the fbi found huawei equipment in
midwest could disrupt nuclear
communications cnn and that is uh from
yesterday i'm gonna send you this jamie
i'm gonna send you some new thing hold
on a second
dang because this is really crazy
um this is some [ __ ] that they found out
where the fbi director uh starts talking
about i'll send you this jamie one
second the fbi director was talking
about how bad
their the chinese
spying is on americans
and he said it's bigger than every other
country combined
why do they want to spy on us though
because what because we or what stealing
intellectual property stealing all your
data stealing credit card numbers
stealing the where you're going tracking
you if you're uh
criticizing the chinese government like
whatever the [ __ ] your control so say
one day they could like
one day would it be possible then if
they take all this information
that they could just like commandeer
like say like a business's website for
sure like sure
and then give me some volume biggest
threat we face as a country from a
counterintelligence perspective is from
the people's republic of china and
especially the chinese communist party
no country presents a broader more
severe
threat to our ideas our innovation our
economic security
than china
and they are targeting our innovation
our
trade secrets our intellectual property
on a scale that's unprecedented in
history they are have a bigger hacking
program than that of every other major
nation combined
they have stolen more of americans
personal and corporate data
than every nation combined what is the
fbi doing about that so the fbi is
keenly focused on the china college
intelligence threat uh we are now moving
at a pace where we're opening a new
china counterintelligence investigation
about every 12 hours
jesus christ
every 12 hours
so
like say one day you could go to a
website right to buy something okay yeah
and china has the information of the
website it has your information
and they could wonder if they could like
put their own website over it so you
actually just buy it and they send it to
you from china and they make the money
and that company never even gets there
i'm sure they could do that be even
worse how about this maybe you develop
something you develop some new
innovative technology all right but you
develop it using an internet that's
connected with huawei devices or some
other device that the chinese government
has infiltrated and put third-party
access to so they they infiltrate all of
your secrets and when you go to market
they've already created it so they
already have put people to work building
the thing that you have worked so hard
to develop they they put engineers on it
and they do it so all of our
intellectual property all of our
creative pursuits in terms of like
innovation they
they steal all that wow and they just do
they build it over there you know they
have apple stores in china that have
nothing to do with apple everything's
counterfeit oh dude one time i went to
this starbucks one time in jamaica right
somebody had
we went in there and uh
they somebody had just stolen a
starbucks sign and put it up outside of
this place
so we go in and the guy's like welcome
to the starbucks lounge he's like can i
get you a smoothie
i was in jamaica yeah dude so it was
just he just had a starbucks sign it was
like a smoothie shop dude it was so
ridiculous bro well other countries have
like totally different rules in terms of
what you can get away with and what you
can and china's rules are wild you know
they have versions of uh
world cities that they've built replicas
of in china like they have a version of
paris
have you seen that
google a chinese version of paris
because they have the kind of money they
have in china and because they have like
free rein to do whatever the [ __ ] they
want they've literally built
cities that they don't even use oh i
wonder if uh
what are you wondering
i'm trying to think what i'm wondering
look at this
the eiffel tower left is one of paris
most iconic landmarks the second largest
replica in the world can be found in
boy say that word
chang
tian du chang
chan
after the paris las vegas hotel in
nevada look at that one on the right
that is a fake
eiffel tower
it looks exactly like it but it's in
china but that's just like us just but
look they build the buildings yeah do
you have to sign in for this [ __ ]
everything email but look they they made
all the different buildings there that's
what's wild like they've recreated
everything
they've recreated look at that
i mean that is [ __ ] wild they
recreate the building on the corner they
were they created all this [ __ ]
look at that it's in china oh yeah
that's the
replica it's a huge replica of paris
like they've literally reproduced paris
what do you do one thing it's wild about
china you ride on the trains and
sometimes they have these buildings and
they're just they built them but there's
no windows they're just like completely
abandoned but they're
huge high-rises just everywhere there's
nothing in them like yeah exactly it's
the same thing that's what we're talking
about like they they they have the
ability to do stuff like that that we
just don't have what do they do if
somebody dies over there they bury them
or they don't care
i don't know i mean they can definitely
make you disappear over there